All right, link me the Guam video about
that tweet, Kathy.
Or if there's another goodw video
recently, send it to me.
>> Thank you for the $5 off. Thank you.
Thank you. I think the due video. What
due video?
>> You could actually do the work you say
you've been spend.
>> Yeah, that's cool. But how many pinball
machines did all that moral superior it
by you?
>> Facts, Jimy. Facts. You know, Jim,
you you really you can't put a price on
integrity. You really can't.
You really can't. But guys, if you'd
like to attempt, now's a great time to
remind you.
>> A decade doing and give some information
like, "Wow, it's crazy that this
synagogue
sends money directly to the IDF. But no,
of course you didn't [__] do that
because you would get eaten alive by
your fans.
Unlike Kathan, I'm going to give you
some context
that doesn't excuse anti-semitism. Here
is this video. This is a
>> so I like just getting through the show.
I want to carry on with the content.
Thank you, Quell. Thank you. Huge
appreciate, Quell. Thank you for the
five gifted. Thank you. Thank you.
Shilling is a necessity. Okay. Shilling
should be quick, painless. Let's get
through it. Let's get back into the
content. Get back to delivering the
product you're here for.
>> Synagogue in Miami, Florida. Welcoming
Netanyahu. Okay. giving him a hero's
welcome.
>> Okay.
Really jazzed to have him there.
>> Thank you for the $5. Okie dokie. Huge
appreciate. Thank you.
>> Okay.
Obviously, yuck. Right. Netanyahu sucks.
Here is what Hassan chose to say, right?
Here is what Assan chose to say.
I've spent the last decade talking about
the separation of Zionism and Judaism.
No, you [__] haven't.
Acting like that has been one of your
crusades
to parse the difference between Judaism
and Zionism is so [__] stupid, bro.
And while conceptually,
>> okay, I'm not going to lie, sure, saying
it's why it was crusades, I feel like
presenting anything as like being a big
crusade or making a difference is kind
of cringe. But wasn't this one of their
core disagreements? Well, the core
disagreements of the drama that you're
covering, wasn't it Ethan and Hassan
disagreeing about whether Judaism and
Zionism are linked?
Ethan's like um 90% Jews is Jews or
whatever the stat is 80% whatever it is.
That's like one of the core
disagreements is about, you know, to how
much you how anti-ionist can you be
before it's anti-Semitic. Can you be
anti-ionist without being anti-semitic?
You know,
it is true. So, while conceptually it's
true that Zionism and Judaism are
different, these sorts of images make a
much stronger argument against said
separation.
So he's saying while conceptually
it is true that these things are
different, the reality is this is a this
is a very strong argument
in in the opposing sense.
>> Yeah, he's obviously saying strong in
terms of effect. That's why he's saying
people wonder why anti-semitism grows.
He's saying this is a compelling,
impactful,
persuasive argument. That's obviously
the point here.
Then people wonder why anti-semit
>> Yeah, exactly. We already went over this
earlier in the segment, but yeah, she is
missing the point where he is saying, "I
argue they're separate. This stuff makes
it really [__] hard."
That's that's clearly the point here,
right? Obviously, I'm sure anyone who
has a high school level reading
comprehension ability can pass that from
this tweet.
Not Guam, though. Not Guam. Not Guam.
Grows. This is a big part of the reason
why. So, let's let's talk about this
because everyone's saying like, "Oh, you
misinterpreted it." No, I [__]
didn't. This is literally him saying,
"Well, Jews, that's why everyone hates
you because one synagogue in Miami."
>> Yeah, that's that's celebrated.
Netanyahu being there.
>> That's That's why it says these sorts,
right? Because he's saying this one
event causes it.
>> That's what That's what the phrase these
sorts means, right? It means this
specific one on its own with nothing
else happening. Thank you, Glam. Thank
you.
>> And because of that,
that's why anti-semitism is rampant.
Let's let's let's do a little digging
because for him to say he spent all this
time
separating,
>> imagine after 9/11,
a mosque in the United States welcomes
Bin Laden. gives Bin Laden a hero's
welcome.
Let's Let's swap out some words and
imagine the tweet about that.
Would we really be crying about that
tweet? Would we really be crying about
that tweet? No, we wouldn't. It would be
obvious. Why is this [__] stupid
mosque welcoming Bin Laden when he just
killed 3,000
Americans in in a terrorist attack?
Aren't you kind of connecting your
religion with the acts of radical
terrorist groups?
This is going to this is going to fuel
Islamophobia.
That would be a totally reasonable
comment to make.
Judaism from Zionism. He didn't do it
here where it might actually done some
good with his platform, right? He didn't
separate the two. Of course there are
like hyper Zionist Jews, right? Of
course there are who just [__] love
Israel down
and some to the point of like we want to
exterminate everyone else and expand
Israel, right? Of course those people
exist. That's who the settlers are,
right? In the West Bank. But let's talk
about
let's talk about this specific synagogue
because he is he is just presenting this
as any synagogue in America. This could
be any synagogue in America that this is
happening in.
And because of that this is why
>> where is that in the tweet? Where is
that in the tweet? Literally everyone
knows, Hassan knows, 95% of Hassan's
audience, probably 80% of Twitter at
large understands there are different
Jews who have different beliefs about
Israel. For instance, there are, you
know, I believe is Orthodox Jews don't,
you know, are totally against it. You
know, there are different Jews have
different thoughts in Israel. Yes. So,
it's not every synagogue is like this.
Every reasonable person knows this.
Obviously, it's about the the argument
the image presents
>> of Israel down
and some to the point of like we want to
exterminate everyone else and expand
Israel, right? Of course, those people
exist. That's who the settlers are,
right, in the West Bank. But let's talk
about
let's talk about this specific synagogue
because he is he is just presenting this
as any synagogue in America. This could
be any synagogue in America that this is
happening in.
And because of that, this is why
anti-semitism happens. Let me It took me
two [__] seconds to find out what
synagogue this happened in. What? Um,
what?
>> Yeah, exactly, dude. So, you're just
like bringing stuff up that's just like
so funny in chat here. And the
synagogues are also the place where
Israel has land auctions for the West
Bank. It looks really bad. Yeah, it you
saying that just immediately reminds me
of when aristocracy there's that
compilation of aristocracies like JN
meltdown
where she's talking about how crazy it
is for Jews in Canada now and she's
talking about this synagogue being
protested or attacked or whatever. It's
like it got like got like got like
graffitied because it was a synagogue
that was hosting West Bank land auctions
and it's like yeah I it can be really
scary and not every Jew there is
probably a massive Zionist and whatever
but holy [__] you can't just go oh well
it's a oh you don't understand I can't
do the [__] voice it's a it's a
religious place it's a religious place
you got it's a religious place it's a
religious place you got you got you I
like you can't just do that when you're
doing [__] land auctions for your
settled [__] stolen land that you're
settling right now. You can't you can't
do that. No, it's getting protested cuz
you're doing some [__] up [__] there.
That's why that's why you're getting
[__] protested. Obviously,
what school of Judaism
they belong to and their politics.
Okay, took me two [__] seconds.
Okay, so NBC Miami did a whole article
about
about Nanyahu visiting. And so they talk
about the shul of of Ball Harbor, which
is an Orthodox synagogue.
An orthodox synagogue. That's like the
most hardcore you can be without being
hidic if I if I know things correctly.
Okay.
>> Okay.
>> I'm pretty sure or the Orthodox is like
super duper kosher. They are they are
hardcore in their religion. Okay.
Orthodox synagogue. Okay. Right there.
There are a lot of different schools of
Judaism or
>> Okay. But what I mean is she's saying
it's most hardcore. But yeah, but aren't
Orthodox Jews against Israel generally?
So I mean to say oh well you don't Yeah.
So it dep I understand it depends a
little bit. It doesn't. It depends. But
my understanding is that just saying oh
they're orthodox. They're they're really
Jewish. It's not like saying you know
someone's like a
super conservative Christian and like
all the stuff that comes along with
that. It's like um there's I think maybe
even it is cuz they're not all the same
either. But to say oh they're Orthodox
obviously they support Israel. is
orthodox. Obviously, they're welcoming
Netanyahu. Not everyone's orthodox.
Orthodox a tiny amount. That doesn't say
you're not actually addressing the point
there. You're not saying anything. Like
the level of um fundamentalism or
orthodoxy in belief does not necessarily
correlate with Israel sport. Like dude,
and we say like these same retards will
sit there and cry about Hassan being
ignorant or whatever the [__]
>> Categories. I don't know what the what
the term is. disciplines of Judaism,
right? Orthodox an Orthodox synagogue in
Miami, Florida is very different from an
Orthodox synagogue in New York City.
Even
>> the most extreme foreign against Zionism
pretty even split though from my
understanding the middle ground. Yeah,
that makes sense,
>> right? So even within
the the school of orthodoxy there there
are differences. Okay.
And and and the article makes sure to
say
that even in Israel, even in Israel,
people living in Israel [__]
>> What difference does this make to
Hassan's point? Literally, what
difference does this make?
>> Hate Netanyahu. He has a 53% disapproval
rating back home. So for him even to say
that that Zionism supports what's
happening in Palestine is [__]
[__]
His motivational message was re received
with great enthusiasm.
>> The Dioro PDF allegations are going to
hit like crack.
>> I I wish, man. Honestly, sadly, I don't
think Dioro is a pedophile.
Unfortunately, guys, I don't think we
will ever get the Dioro pedophile
allegations. I I'm like, it breaks my
heart to say it truly.
here in South Florida.
Okay. He is undoubtedly more popular
right now in Surfside, that's the town
that this is that this happened in, than
he is in Tel Aviv or the neighborhood in
in Miami.
So multiple times in this article, they
are sure to mention
that even Israelis
hate Netanyahu more than this [__]
super orthodox church or synagogue,
excuse me, in Miami. So these people are
very extreme.
>> Even Israelis hate hate Netanyahu more
than these people do. Okay, these Jewish
people are very extreme.
So then I went to the Schul's website.
>> What? Like seriously, what does she
think this is proving? What what do we
think we're proving here?
>> Multiple places on the on the homepage
to donate
directly to the IDF.
This is not something
that most
most synagogues are doing.
>> Okay.
>> This place is like hardcore,
not even just Zionist, like pro-IDF.
Okay.
>> Okay.
>> Netanyahu chose this synagogue on
purpose.
>> Okay.
>> They are extremely IDF friendly.
>> And then I zoomed out, right? I was I
was looking at the the
>> this it changes nothing about what's
been said. This is totally just dressing
>> synagogue itself and then I zoomed out
to look at Surfside. Surfside is the
neighborhood this is happening in. The
town is mostly Jewish. There are like
multiple
>> okay
>> synagogues within walking distance of
each other. And I will guarantee you
that each of those synagogues is doing
something completely different.
Surfside is considered to be many by
many to be Miami's most Jewish
neighborhood. It is home to under 6,000
people. So it's very very small and has
at least 2500 Orthodox Jews
and they're from all over the place.
Okay. So then I was like, "Okay, well,
just to make sure, just to make sure
these aren't libs, right? These aren't
libs supporting Benjamin Netanyahu and
cheering for
>> what Julie, what point does she think
she's making?
No matter what she says here about the
split of opinion in Surfside or
whatever, her son's point will still
stand. Thank you for the $5, easy. Thank
you.
The point is
drawing a super close public visible
association
between the religion and the actions of
uh the state and military will increase
anti-semitism
regardless of what Hassan tries to argue
or whatever that those images will
increase that the relationship people
see between the religion and the actions
and will fuel anti-semitism.
It's not to say that's justified.
Obviously, you know, no lefty is going
to say that bigotries are justified.
They're not going to say it's that would
be [__] [__] but it will happen.
It's a foreseeable outcome
>> in Miami.
I decided to look.
>> Did you see her using Teddy Glow? No. Is
there a video of her using Teddy Glow?
Like,
>> okay.
As soon as I saw where it was, I was
like, this is in [__] Dade County.
Like these people are super
conservative.
Of course they are.
>> Jesse Smlet in chat saying, "Yeah, they
do it. They do it as long as it's
against Whitey."
Thank you, Jesse Smlet.
>> Supporting Netanyahu in Israel, right?
They're [__] Republicans.
Yeah, it's a neighborhood, not a city.
It's a neighborhood of Miami, but the
neighborhoods are big because Miami is
huge.
So I zoomed out even further. So now
we've looked at the synagogue. The
synagogue itself is super super like
conservative orthodox,
not conservative in the Jewish sense,
conservative in like political.
>> Hardcore love the IDF.
Really want you to send your money to
the IDF. That is not common for starters
right in America. Zoom out. Surfside.
The the neighborhood in which this is
happening
full of Orthodox Jews,
right? Who are very politically
conservative. Zoom out even more.
Surfside
is I think the the precinct was 010.
Yeah, 010.0
is the precinct for Surfside.
Trump won by a [__] landslide in this
neighborhood.
>> Okay.
>> Yeah, it's it's Florida.
>> This is not common.
This is not common. Okay.
This is an extremely conservative area
with an extremely orthodox, hardcore
Zionist
synagogue that is like IDF first.
These are hardcore Republicans.
So for Hassan to look at this and say
and do do none of the work I just did
that took me two seconds do none of the
work to say
>> what would it change about his comment
>> to actually work on the separation of
Zionism and Judaism and instead to say
this is why this is why anti-semitism
grows this is a big reason
because
a super conservative ative synagogue
did something super conservative
which is support Netanyahu just like
Trump he didn't say this is the reason
this is a big part of the reason
the reason here being the connection
between Israel Zionism the actions of
the IDF and Judaism right that's the
reason here that connection is the to
Hassan. The reason why inseatism is
growing,
this is a big part of how people get the
connection drawn by having images like
this.
What?
Wait, she's going to have to she got to
be clear. I really do not see the issue
with this tweet.
>> This is a big reason.
>> Again, I just I would just take it back
to the Bin Laden example. How much time
did you spend on the VOD covering star
limp? Beta male responses to Trump
invading Vu Vu.
>> I haven't done it yet. I haven't done it
yet. We will. And yes, I know
Zar has been totally weak on the
Venezuela stuff, but hey, look, the UK
and France signing security deals with
Ukraine
and they said, you know, we stand with
Greenland, S with Denmark, whatever. So,
look, I'm hoping
it's all going to be fine. Nothing ever
happens. Nothing ever happens. So, we're
going to be fine.
>> A super conservative synagogue
>> did something super conservative,
>> which is support Netanyahu just like
Trump is doing.
This would have been a great time to
say, "Hey guys,
I know you might think that this is this
is what all Jews feel, but it's not.
This is actually a very extreme
synagogue in a very conservative
city
in a very conservative county in a very
conservative state.
>> Yeah. I I just bring it back to the Bin
Laden example again. You could like
imagine you take Bin Laden to a mosque.
Someone's like, you know, I argue about
the separation of
Islam and,
you know, radical terrorist groups all
the time. Images like this make it
really [__] difficult being out here
saying this [__]
I wish that I wish they'd stop doing
this [__] you know?
Be totally reasonable comment to make.
It would be a totally reasonable comment
to make.
here does not reflect the opinion, the
experience of the Jewish diaspora.
No, he did none of that. He just said,
"Yeah, Jews, this is why everyone hates
you."
>> Okay,
>> you could do something to fight back
about these images and the argument they
make.
Dude, he does literally like a core
argument that him and Ethan have had the
whole time is about whether Judaism and
Zionism are linked is about like the
whole 80% Jew Zionists. Sam Cedar even
argued Ethan about it. What the [__] do
you mean? This is one of the points I've
heard sour. I don't even watch the guy
and this is one of the points I've heard
because the argument they are making
that you are co-signing
is that there is no separation between
Zionism and Judaism. Like, wow, no
wonder people feel that way.
You could do you could actually do the
work. You
>> Wendy, can you just send me the time
stamp to this Teddy stuff?
>> You say you've been spending a decade
doing
and give some information. Like, wow,
it's crazy that this synagogue
sends money directly to the IDF. But no,
of course you didn't [__] do that
because you would get eaten alive by
your fans. People be like, "Yeah, but
that is that's how all Jews feel."
Yeah, but Jim there like,
okay, we can literally use real world
examples that happen right now. I'm
going to come up with a comment that I
believe and you can tell me where this
is llamophobic.
Um, I'm trying to format it exactly how
Assassan's comment is made.
Let me pull it up.
I've spent a long time talking about the
separation between
radical Islamic terrorism
and uh general practice of Islam. And
well, conceptually it is true
the sorts of images that depict
uh local imams talking violently about
infidels and their children
make a much stronger argument against
that said separation and then people
wonder why uh Islamophobia grows. This
is a big part of the reason why. That's
a comment totally based totally based on
tell me where that's xenonophobic. Tell
me where that's phobic in the way that
this would be anti-semitic.
Obviously, it's not it is not
representative of mosques and [__]
generally that there are these super
extreme preachers.
It is in the more conservative ones. It
is not the the super widely held view.
But it does make a strong argument on
the perceptions
to onlookers about the link. If a son
actually cared about rising
anti-semitism, would he really live in a
mansion and shock his dog? CPS CPS skull
CPS
that Thank you for the input from the
Nicholas Yurio Discord there. So yeah,
please explain to me why that comment
was Islamophobic. I'm waiting on it.
Sorry. Okay. Well, change that comment.
Let's change that comment.
Then people wonder why Islamophobia
grows. This is a big part of the reason
why. And I think they should stop doing
it. I think they should stop inviting
these preachers and stop letting them
speak. What? How's that as xenophobic?
Why does the prescription change it?
And I forgot that was her claim. So, you
won.
Okay. So, you're not defending this as
potentially as antimetic or whatever.
Okay. Well, we got through that. Thank
you for the $20. Huge appreciated with a
thanks for being you. Super sticker with
a pear character looking in the mirror
with hearts bouncing off. Thank you.
Huge appreciate. Thank you.
>> We didn't [__] do that.
because you would get eaten alive by
your fans. People be like, "Yeah, but
that is that's how all Jews feel."
>> Like, where is he saying that?
>> It's [__] insane.
Yeah. God for God forbid he actually
have some nuance here.
>> And maybe he talked about the difference
between Zionism and Judaism before
October 7th, but you know, he [__]
hasn't since.
>> You're asking maybe another food shop
video. Yeah, I heard literally everyone
has covered the London trip drama. J So,
food shops, harmful opinions,
sleepy, everyone has covered it
>> in any real way. And this is the reason
why
>> people have to keep saying [__] because
you keep [__] maligning them.
If you stopped if you stopped making
them into a this like hateful, horrible
monolith, they wouldn't have to keep
defending themselves and centering
themselves while while Palestine is
being genocided, right? Like you keep
clapping in their direction. What are
they supposed to do? Think of somebody
who's just never met Jewish people
before that doesn't understand that
there are different
traditions
of Judaism, right?
And they see Hassan post this. Like,
listen guys, I've been giving Jews the
benefit of the doubt, but this is crazy.
They're going to think this is how all
Jews in America feel.
>> Okay.
>> Wow. Look at all these Jews. They
[__] love Netanyahu.
They're supporting him.
I don't know. Maybe it's better that
Hassan didn't talk about the like the
name and location of the actual super
extreme
uh extreme Zionist synagogue, right?
Because I feel like violence probably
would have happened if he had. But dude,
to say that's the reason why
anti-semitism grows. No, anti-
anti-semitism is on the rise because
people [__] hate Jewish people. Like
like anti-semitism, it's literally
circular. Anti-semitism is on the rise
because anti-semitism is on the rise.
People hating Jews is on the rise
because people hate Jews.
Okay. But why? Why? What has happened?
What are the causes?
Something. Anti-semitism was lower. Now
it's getting higher.
Why is that? There must be a causal
explanation for it. We understand people
are anti-semitic. We're looking for the
causal explanation. Now, do we feel like
anti-semitism has gone up drastically in
the past, say, two or so years? Do we
And then we get round to Hassan's point.
And then we get round to Hassan's point
eventually.
>> It's not because a synagogue in Miami
held a really weird
>> event. We're all at home scratching our
heads as to as to why anti-semitism is
on the rise. Why is anti-semitism on the
rise
for Netanyahu?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I When I say
conservative, I know it's confusing
because I'm thinking conservative
politically
um not conservative Judaism.
So, I'll just say like Republicans for
for when I'm talking about like
Republican Jewish people who are like
Trumpy. Like these are [__] Trumpy
Jewish people. So, yeah, it's just
stupid. It's so stupid.
But it's easy. It's easy for people to
believe because they want they want a
scapegoat. They want a reason that this
is happening, right? They want it to be
some like big
evil cabal
because it is something so big and evil
that
>> just throw out all the due words, guys.
Throw all the Jew words.
>> Find your nearest Jewish person and let
them know you have their back during
these times.
>> Thank you for the $5. Thank you.
Appreciate. Thank you. Good morning.
Thank you.
>> And it's easy for people to buy because
there are so few Jews in the world.
just a couple million that so many
people have never even [__] met one.
And so it's easy to just be like that's
what all Jews are like. Yes, MAGA Jews.
Republican Jews is so antithetical. You
would think so.
You would think so, but let me I mean,
let me show you the numbers again.
Look at this [__] This is the This is
the the neighborhood. This is the
neighborhood where this synagogue is.
This is their precinct
from the from the 2024 election.
78%
in a town in a neighborhood that is
overwhelmingly Jewish and over and what
like a uh more than almost half. Wait,
is that
Yeah, almost half of them are Orthodox.
And look at this [__] There are there
are MAGA Jewish people.
They are the outliers. Like this is the
[__] like Hassan, you have a you have a
huge platform and I think that that
means you have a responsibility to
impart some sort of [__] nuance, but
you don't care. You just wanted to fire
off a [__] tweet
that everybody that follows you would
love.
>> Okay. She's been looping for ages now.
She's running out of stuff to say. Okay.
We need
to find the Teddy Trion.
>> Your lips look blue in this light.
>> I want the extra segment. I want the I
don't want the clip I've been sent. I
want to see the full whole full thing.
That's important. Wait, was this you
just checked?
Just saw me just check.
Kathy linked a video in the farm. Oh,
brilliant. Brilliant. Brilliant. Here we
go.
>> And y'all can let me know if that's too
loud, not loud.
Prime your face. And I really thought I
don't know why I'm putting it on my
head.
>> Here we go. Here we go. That's just a
like especially like here where it's
like really dry. It's nice to have the
primer cuz then the [__] just like
slides over it.
Okay,
now we are working through a foundation
that is definitely too light for my skin
tone,
but that's okay. We're just going to
keep using it until it's gone.
My son packed it.
>> I was literally about to say it's like
literally don't even bother. It's so low
brow to say any lipstick on a pig jokes.
So low brow. It's unfucking believable.
And what why what do you know? within
moments.
Within moments, the whole chat is camp's
going to pick.
Oh my god,
>> that I can't I don't know what that
conversation was. I'm just going to I'm
just going to mind my business.
Is the volume okay for the music?
I'm just going to do my face.
Wait, I'm crying.
Yeah, it definitely is way too light,
but I don't want to waste it.
Uh, this is an Ilia
tinted moisturizer
and it's just a little too light for me,
I think. I mean, maybe not.
It might just feel that way because I
have [__] rosacea.
Who knows? Doesn't look as bad right now
as it has.
Do a little on the forehead.
And yeah. Well, with the primer,
it just glides. I mean, this is
I'm thinking about getting one of those.
There's this um I keep getting ads for
it. It's like a blurring balm. Have you
guys seen these?
And I feel like it's kind of similar to
like a tinted moisturizer. And that
looks that looks even lighter than this.
I like to I don't usually wear a full
face of makeup. If I were going to I
would need something that doesn't look
like doesn't get dry on me. And so I'm
wondering if the if like a blurring balm
will work.
Who knows? All right, let's get into
this look.
Let's skip ahead, girly.
All right, what are we starting with
again? This is Alysia Aragon.
a nice blank canvas base. And this is in
the shade persuade. And this is just
going to give me a nice blank canvas and
really cancel out any redness on my eye
area. Sorry with my
>> How's this going? How's this? How's the
process?
>> This is Teddy Glow. And this is Teddy
Glow on the inside so far.
Let's keep going, girl.
See? And once I was satisfied, I decided
to go in and cut my crease with some
concealer. As you can see, I put it down
towards the lash line first. And then I
look up and it kind of gives me a
guideline as to where my faux creases
customade shape. That just really opens
up the eye area. Helps to give me a
larger space because I do have hooded
lids. And then once I'm done with that
and kind of satisfied with both sides, I
take a little detail.
>> All right. So now we're like defining.
I need a little tiny brush
because we are about to define.
It's gonna just like
>> Okay.
>> Make sure that the two colors are
blended nicely together. You'll probably
want to go back and forth between the
pink and
>> All right. I'll pack in a little Look at
that.
All right. Stuff. Okay. All
right, that's